the first thing we're going to do is
cure diseases right you'll go in and
stop people from having different kind
of down syndrome right exactly exactly
exactly so obvious ones and we all have
to agree what to cure because even that
has ethical issues that's true for
example the American Association of
psychiatrist it wasn't until 1987 where
they removed
homosexuality from the Encyclopedia of
mental disorders oh it used to be in
there yes
so you asked the question it was before
1987 or even earlier and you had the
medical capacity to quote fix someone
whose genetic profile if that's where
it's found it makes them gay would you
do that
back then they probably would because
that's a disorder they thought it was a
mental distance and then you find out
that at least 15 of the one out of six
is this at what point is it a disorder
and what point is it's just the natural
variation of who we are as a species
damn that's crazy so the guy who's
writing the disorders obviously was a
straight guy
perceptive right on and and there's the
guy what's his neuroscientist I always
forget his name but I guess if you're
super straight say you're super straight
you wandering out of a cave or whatever
right you're a straight guy you see him
I know that I'm straight can I tell you
how I know I'm straight how I know I'm
straight because
I wrestled for eight years
the muscled sinewy sweaty bodies of
other men yeah and at no time did I even
have a tingle in my body it's like I'm
gonna pin your ass to the mat and get up
and walk away okay that's what I'm good
I was Captain of my high school's
wrestling team I'm just thinking my
hands are all over men's bodies if I had
any urge I would have felt it then so I
think I do one two three four and you
still have to tapping out the longer you
stay there oh it's counting the thing
but I think yeah you just stay there and
don't tap because it feels good I think
that's crazy baby yeah so so so I'm I'm
just gender heterosexual do you ever
wonder if you could ever but because
some people think you could evolve into
it like I you know I wouldn't like I I
would wonder if one day I could be when
I'm 70 years old be a homosexual you
know I don't I don't know all the
drivers and causes and what's genetic
and what's cultural I I don't know I
don't even care it's just whatever
people want to be in a free country let
them be that yeah right so to even argue
it it's like that's like arguing should
someone wear their hair one way or the
other where the part it's it's how you
express but I would say I'm a straight
guy you got your moment and you're
rocking that you've been rocking the
mullet from day one that's your thing if
you came out with an afro you're
somebody else at that point yeah but
this country allows that I don't know if
your fans would allow it but the country
would allow it like okay
what about this so I think yeah I could
see if you're a straight guy you're
writing the book right on what is a
straight psychiatrist right right in the
book you see a guy you know you're
hanging out with your buddies one of
them reaches for another guy's wiener or
whatever I could see you being like oh
this is uh this is but do you think he
thought it was wrong or he just thought
just it simply I don't know that they
value judge they're just saying it's a
disorder right in need of repair
so but it was a disorder based on that
things are just supposed to be this way
because they had whatever biases they
had whatever
inability to embrace the spectrum of
humanity presented to him right does
nature is nature just or does nature gay
also oh okay uh their books on this
Evolution's rainbow okay which explores
what species out there actually have
full spectrum sex okay gay sex bang sex
there's some there's rape in some
there's Dolphins there's some there's no
other way to understand it unless okay
so there's a full range of what's and I
don't care if there's a line called or
so here's my point
that I don't know that we should care
what the rest of the animal kingdom is
doing do you know there's a there's a
mole rat that's called this this comes
in a mole rat where one variant on it
they mate for life and the other one
there is promiscuous as go all get out
damn and they're both mole rats I got
bavarians
so they're both they're both mole rats
so and then people say oh Eagles mate
forever and they want that to be we want
to emulate that and then you find out
that Bonnabel chimps they're all
the time oh to resolve differences to to
fight each just look at this video yeah
it's behind the wall you gotta go behind
the wall on the video but and so and but
also very close to us genetically my
point is we're human I don't care what
the other animals are doing you can find
an animal that'll support or or deny
whatever claim you're trying to make
about us so forget them we're our own
species yeah and that's true we have the
capacity to Grant freedoms in some
governments to your
to support your happiness we value that
yeah that's cool because it's crazy to
think that some countries don't right
that's why I'm glad I'm in America yeah
am I good at that right am I getting
like a B plus
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one